vous les aviez avant vous en aviez
d'autres pas cela mais vous aviez
d'autres non oui bien sûr de louer
d'autres qui assurent leur nom vous
faisait des raisons non mais vous avez
raison bien sûr c'est pour ça je vous
dis on n'est jamais à l'abri de faire de
commettre une erreur c'est ce que je
vous dis mais à partir du moment où on a
souhaité
s'engager davantage sur une radio
généraliste mais qui donne davantage de
parts à l'information notamment le matin
puisque maintenant que nous avons plus
qu'en plus il n'est pas remplacé par un
autre par un autre humoriste donc c'est
bien c'est bien la preuve que ce n'est
pas monsieur canteloup qui posait
problème ils n'osaient pas d'ailleurs
mais donc on a souhaité faire un format
qui est un format plus
d'information et de débat parce qu'on
estimait que c'était plus dans
l'état d'esprit que robin pouvait avoir
qui n'empêche pas qu'on a un matthieu
noël à cet arrêt car enfin bon on a un
peu plus tard à 18h45 bon on n'a pas
abandonné cette ligne là non plus vous
nous dites formellement dans votre
réponse oui vous pouvez me re dire
d'ailleurs oui que monsieur que tout
c'est pas parce qu'il a moqué monsieur
bolloré quoi de condat jugé que c'était
plus une émission que c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui ramenait de l'audience qui
aimait oui vous avez bien sûr donc se
débarrasser comme ça quand on quand on
est une radio qui on est en perte
d'audience et c'est pas la première
chose à laquelle on pense de 2,2 dira au
revoir monsieur canteloup donc vous me
confirmer que ça n'a aucun rapport vous
savez s'il savait s'il y avait eu un
problème éditoriale avec monsieur quand
louche prend son sens serait séparé
depuis longtemps parce que avant
monsieur bolloré encore il n'a pas moqué
souvent j'étais probablement dans l'est
dans le top 3 des personnes qu'ils qui
taquinaient si je puis dire peut-être
que vous supporte mieux que monsieur
bolloré non non non non je personnes ne
supportent ça c'est juste voilà la
pluralité comme vous le dites et puis
vous rend vie avec et je pense pas que
monsieur canteloup d'ailleurs enfin je
l'espère parce que ce serait comment
dirais-je décevant de sa part dit ce
qu'il a été évincé pour des raisons
éditoriales
il a toujours eu la liberté éditoriale
toujours toujours toujours vincent
capo-canellas ce toujours
[Musique]